well last month you went to Houston and
reported from George Floyd's funeral
what was the most powerful moment of
that experience for you well within a
week I did I was in Houston but before
that I was in Minneapolis for the
memorial service I think the most
powerful moment for me was that when
Reverend Sharpton was in the eulogy and
he said let's pause for eight minutes
and 46 seconds and I was outside the
church I'm seeing the sea of people out
there and just looking at the faces some
people were crying some people were
praying some people were just
shell-shocked I think I was in the
shell-shocked category of trying to
imagine that period of time it's a long
long time of course it references the
time that the officers me was on George
Floyd's neck but I think that that
really moved me just just you know you
look you've seen the video but you see
through different different lens when
you really feel that length of time yeah
I was gonna say sitting there for that
long
it really puts things in perspective of
how how how long it actually is is what
you're saying but you know as a
journalist
what makes Floyd's story different from
others like it that you've covered
because unfortunately there's been a lot
of stories of people dying that should
not have died and and or police
brutality or just any instance that's
kind of in a similar vein there's we
hear about so many Brianna Taylor it's
me right sweetie we hear about so many
so what what do you think makes made
this one different I think because we
were all eyewitnesses to it you're
you're right we've seen many of these
cases and very often ends up being
jumbled you know dashcam video or body
cam video this was a rather steady shot
of a man being suffocated to death and
there's no there's no equivocating that
there's no walking around there's no
like maybe it could have been this or
that it was what you saw and when you
bear witness to something that awful you
can't walk away from it you can't
discount it you can't leave it to other
people and so I think you know when I
look at and sometimes the protesters
come right here by my apartment I look
out and I see black why
Asians and Hispanics I see rainbows
people here as human beings who are
saying no it doesn't stand in our
society so I think you know his case
just just it symbolized so many things
we've seen but it was just so graphic
and so awful and as I said we are all
eye witnesses to it yeah I know I I
agree with that it's on film it's hard
to negate that subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel please
don't make me keep going